[Music]
toys can be pretty creepy lots of people
are spooked by dolls Ouija boards and
other playthings but some toys seem to
be creepy beyond explanation don't take
your eyes off the screen until you've
seen the scariest side to everyone's
favorite holiday elf if this is your
first time watching the things hit that
subscribe button and give this pookie
video a big thumbs up let's jump right
in and investigate 10 haunted toys
caught on camera sneaky doll dolls are
already a little creepy they're tiny
lifeless people they're dull eyes can be
downright spooky dolls are also very
beautiful and many are pretty expensive
lots of people enjoy collecting them
cheri shewn is an avid doll collector
she has an extensive collection which
appears to contain many porcelain and
possibly antique dolls Sheree
inadvertently captured more than just
the size of her collection when filming
her dolls one day this clip captures the
terrifying moment that one of Sheree's
dolls appears to move on its own as the
camera pans across her impressive
collection a deep eye doll seems to move
its right arm no one can be seen
controlling the toy there are no visible
wires or strings either for those who
are afraid of the human-like toys this
is a nightmare scenario for some just
looking at dolls is enough to inspire a
feeling of unease being in a room full
of them and seeing one move would be
enough to send most people running can
you imagine seeing an inanimate object
move on its own perhaps the most
disturbing part of the video is that
Sheree doesn't seem to notice anything
is amiss as she films her toys the
camera continues to pan smoothly away
and capture the rest of the collection
it's as if nothing had even happened
this video is enough to put anyone off
dolls for good twisted metal the twisted
metal series are video games all about
demolition derby not only complains use
their vehicle to smash their opponents
but they can spice things up with
outlandish weapons and items crushing a
car with an ice cream truck is really
fun
mounting a mess
launcher onto that ice cream truck is
even better the games and characters are
all a little dark and rough in this
video a person can be seen playing with
a toy version of one of the game's most
iconic vehicles this ice cream truck is
aptly named sweet tooth the drive is a
deranged killer dressed as a clown who
goes by the name needles cane YouTube
user Trilly Billy demonstrates that the
batteries are out of the controller of
their version of the truck there
shouldn't be any power to it to send
signals to the remote-controlled toy
every time truly Billy reaches for the
toy it inexplicably turns on this
strange effect is demonstrated over and
over as a hand reaches toward the toy
and it answers with some mechanical
buzzing each time the controller is
displayed as well as the 12 volt battery
for which it is clearly detached we
can't explain why this toy behaves this
way but it's obvious something strange
is happening creepy laughter Ghost
Adventures is a show in which three
friends investigate allegedly haunted
locations each week the show's stars
travel to a new place and delve into
local mysteries and ghost stories in one
particularly creepy episode the crew
goes to Mexico to investigate a world
famous spot the island of dolls is a
mysterious tourist destination full of
toys and dolls the island was never
meant to gain so much attention from
travelers it has a sad origin story that
fits its creepy atmosphere the island
began to be filled with dolls after a
young girl drowns in the canals
surrounding it the islands caretaker Don
Julian Santana Barrera found the girl
and was consumed with grief a few years
later he saw a doll floating in the
canal believing it belonged to the girl
he hung it in a tree to honor her memory
from that day the collection began to
grow until it covered the entire island
the crew venture into a structure to
find a doll named Steven as they explore
in the dark an unseen toy in another
room begins to laugh maniacally
the sound is blood-curdling the crew
investigates the source of the noise and
find a wall of dolls and severed parts
the scene is chilling
[Music]
spinning pinwheel YouTube user
paranormal 64 enjoys visiting haunted
places and investigating local legends
in this video he stops a local graveyard
with his son to visit a child's grave
the pair brings along a classic purple
pinwheel toy and places it in the ground
by the headstone the person behind the
camera invites any spirits of children
who may be nearby to play with the
pinwheel if they'd like almost
immediately the toy begins to spin as if
on its own this seems to catch the men
off-guard the video appears to have been
shot on a cell phone getting a clearer
view of the conditions and surroundings
is difficult
paranormal 64 says that there's no wind
that night and tries to film blades of
grass to prove it it's hard to see how
still the wind is so we may never know
what actually happened was it the spirit
of a child happy to have some company
and a toy to play with
was it a clever trick or maybe there was
just a breeze that night no matter what
you believe it's hard to deny that the
video is spooky the graveyard is
beautiful and eerily calm at night the
crave stone is a somber reminder of the
child that passed away this video
creates an extremely creepy vibe and the
sight of the spinning pinwheel is
chilling possessed princess many little
girls love dolls a beautiful new toy can
be an exciting and treasured gift a
video posted by Eduardo agua on Oh shows
just a moment this could be a happy and
fun video of a young girl receiving an
excellent gift but instead of showcasing
an exciting family memory the video
quickly turns to terror the frame
centers on a young woman who can be seen
cradling a large beautiful doll she
excitedly talks to the camera about her
new friend the toy is wearing a tiara
and a ball gown it looks like a
beautiful princess
the dolls face is directed at the camera
as the girl holds it as she speaks the
dolls head seems to turn on its own to
look up at its new owner understandably
the girl reacts with terror she shrieks
in fear and throws the toy down before
the video abruptly ends it's not clear
how the dolls head could have moved
no one can be seen controlling it or
manipulating it in any way there are no
wire strings or levers visible which
could have turned her head no one
appears anywhere near the girl holding
the toy either
morbid Elmo everyone loves Sesame Street
generations of kids have grown up with
the catchy songs and educational stories
the friendly puppets are a staple of
childhood Elmo might be one of the
sweetest characters on the show
countless toys have been made of Elmo he
saw kids how to tie their shoes tickle
and lots of other skills the friendly
little monster is beloved all around the
world there are thousands of Elmo books
out there one in particular caused a
huge stir and even made its way onto
several news outlets the book is called
potty time with Elmo and features
several sound clips of the character
that goes along with the story most of
the clips are cute and friendly phrases
like hooray and let's try and use the
potty in some recalled copies of the
book there seems to have been a mistake
made in one of the clips in the recalled
book one clip has Elmo laughing and
asking who wants to die what it's not
clear how many copies of this book were
defective the publisher released a
statement that the books had all been
recorded correctly but that they nearly
had a playback error we're glad this was
a simple defect and not an intentional
mistake living doll a YouTube poster
known only as Smith was in for a fright
with the doll in this video Smith
purchased the antique with his wife at a
flea market they didn't know much about
the toy itself except that its type was
no longer produced after the 1940s
nothing seems strange about the doll
until Smith says he put it in the
family's Shaye's that's when the toy
began to move on its own the toy is
already a bit creepy on its own and has
no hair and the expression on its
lifeless face is one of shock and fear
the doll is heavily worn and shows its
age it already looks like a prop from a
horror film
as Smith films the creepy doll it does
appear to begin moving on its own
the dolls right arm slowly starts to
raise and lower we can't see how anyone
could be pushing the toy there's no one
holding it and it appears to be resting
on an uninterrupted surface
as with many videos like this there are
no cables or wires visible that might
hint that the video is a simple prank at
the very end of the clip the dolls body
does shift could that shift be a hint
that someone was controlling the toy
from behind or underneath toy sits up
unlike a lot of videos featuring haunted
toys this one doesn't seem to be focused
on the creepy event this isn't a video
about a creepy toy it's a video of two
kids practicing their cup stacking
routine with their adorable little
brother
we love cup stacking so this video had
us hyped from the beginning we didn't
know we were looking for a creepy
occurrence we could have easily missed
the terrifying action in the background
the girls in the video are standing in
front of a large entertainment center as
the girls stack their cups a toy on a
shelf behind them seems to come to life
the small figure can be seen slowly
sitting up as if it wants to see the fun
stacking action to this tiny detail in
the background takes an otherwise fun
moment and makes it spooky the girls
don't seem to notice what's happening
behind them which is killing our anxiety
we have to assume there was a tripod and
no camera person there's a haunted doll
behind someone you should tell them we
hope the girls weren't too freaked out
when they watched the footage back
summoned teddy bear this video is kind
of unique it involves two creepy toys at
once the video is of a group of young
men sitting around a Ouija board one man
holds the board in his lap while the
others all touched the planchette the
men swirled a planchette around the
board without seeming to stop any
particular letters or symbols as they
play with a toy that's already really
creepy a teddy bear behind them takes
the fear factor to another level no one
has seen holding a controlling the bear
it's resting on top of a dresser just
behind the man holding the board
suddenly the bear begins to move as if
it's been possessed even more disturbing
is that the man holding the board seems
to be feeling uncomfortable he touches
his head and neck as if he's
experiencing a sensation while they use
the board at first no one reacts to the
bear the men seem to not notice it at
all they stand up for a moment and take
a break the video cuts when the men
returned to the board the bear begins to
move
this time the men notice and are
understandably frightened they seem to
flee the room as the video cuts out Elf
on the Shelf this clip is not for the
faint of heart
Elf on the Shelf is one of the most
iconic Christmas toys out there lots of
families can't imagine the holidays
without one everyone's favorite
Christmas sprite takes a surprising and
frightening tone in this video posted by
Arnaldo lopez in the description Arnaldo
says his family's elf is meand carol he
says the video was filmed seven days
before Christmas and it scared his
family to death the video opens on Carol
the elf sitting innocently on what
appears to be a table at first Carol
seems like any other toy as Arnaldo
focuses on her face video becomes
horrifying Carol's beautiful blue eyes
can clearly be seen moving she goes from
starting past Arnaldo to looking
straight into the camera at this point
the video abruptly ends with much
jostling as if the person holding the
recording device runs away this is a
terrifying turn of events that certainly
gives new meaning to the phrase holiday
spirit part of the fun of the elf is the
legend that it moves when no one is
looking families love discovering their
elfs shenanigans and sharing them online
Carol seems to have missed the memo that
she's only supposed to move when no one
is there to see it
we hope you weren't too spooked by these
haunted toys we'll see you later
[Music]